las calles del centro de melbourne la
capital del estado de victoria
nuevamente vacías con una nueva y
repentina orden de confinamiento de
cinco días
australia intenta evitar una tercera ola
de contagios debido a la presencia de la
variante británica de coronavirus
y sé que mucha gente estará dolida hoy
esta no es la posición en la que los
victorianos quisieran estar pero no
puedo tener una situación en la que
dentro de dos semanas miremos atrás y
deseemos haber tomado decisiones
distintas
uno de los eventos afectados por la
decisión es el abierto de australia el
primer gran slam del año que se celebra
hasta el 21 de febrero se prohibió la
entrada a los aficionados hasta el
miércoles miles de personas se vieron
obligadas a abandonar los partidos antes
de la medianoche del viernes
todos los jugadores decían lo mucho que
les gustaba tener algún tipo de público
allí y no tenerlos era diferente para
ellos de todos modos jugarán bien los
veremos por televisión pero sentimos no
poder ir en las últimas 24 horas se
confirmó un nuevo caso adquirido
localmente según informaron este sábado
las autoridades sanitarias de victoria
lo que eleva a 20 el número de casos
activos en el estado el año pasado
members sufrió un cierre de 111 días uno
de los más estrictos y largos del mundo
en ese momento para frenar un brote de
coronavirus que provocó más de 800
muertes